[Music]
hey guys thank you very much for coming
very exciting to see so many people here
turning out for batch compute so we're
gonna talk about large-scale and batch
computing on GCE
I'm gonna introduce the cast of
characters for the next hour I'm Michael
Basilian I'm a product manager in GCE I
work on batch scenarios I also work on
our p on table vm product for those of
you that are familiar with it I make it
my day job to worry about what happens
on GC with respect to batch compute how
customers are using it how we can make
their lives better and so on in the
second half you'll hear from Bert
Holston from he's a system there's an
head for scientific computing at Fermi
National Laboratory and he's going to
talk he's gonna walk you guys through
some very exciting work that they did
some really fundamental science on
Google compute engine how they did it
what the story is and including some of
the science behind it so let's go
quickly through the agenda so we're
gonna start off with an introduction
which is really just one slide about
what batch computing is just because
almost just cause you have to then we're
gonna talk about preemptable VMS which
are near is a product near and dear to
my heart and it's very interesting then
we're gonna talk about storage options
for a batch right so obviously batch
computing doesn't happen in a vacuum
you're not just using a CPU you're
actually storing data and you need to
put that data somewhere and when you
look at the variety of options we have
on GCP there's a lot of them and so I'm
gonna help give you guys a an initial
direction in which you can go in when
designing your architectures and then
we're going to talk about architectures
for batch and obviously we're not going
to talk about just general architectures
for bachelor vacuum we're going to talk
about them in the context of GCP
especially if you're migrating a batch
system to GCP you'll get some idea of
what are different tools and how do you
put them together to make things happen
and of course then everybody's favorite
topic saving money and actually scaling
up and making sure that while you're
scaling up the cost doesn't scale
proportionally with the size of your
compute and then if in the second half
we'll hear from Burt and of course
there'll be a time for Q&A at the end
great all right so what is batch
computing I think we're all kind of
familiar with what batch computing is
but really the way we define it for the
purpose of this talk and in general
really any kind of computation that's
done offline this is as opposed to let's
say online computation like a website or
an application where does a user playing
with it and expect immediate responses
right batch computing is I have a binary
I've got a some amount of data I say hey
computers take this binary run out on
this data give me the results and I'll
come back to it later
some interesting examples are of course
rendering as in the case of movies or
other images transcoding either videos
or audio or images from one format to
another may be reshaping it etc Finance
and Accounting engineering and
scientific simulations of course classic
data analysis is just another former
batch and there's lots of different
modalities there's lots of different
ways people do it
there's embarrassingly parallel or maybe
high throughput computing is sometimes
called and there's always tightly
coupled high performance computing or
MPI
those are all sort of terms used for it
ok let's talk a little bit about
preemptable VMs so what is the principle
vm all right well let's start with the
good parts first of all they're
incredibly cheap they're up to 80%
cheaper than a regular GC virtual
machine that cost around one cent per
core hour they're very easy to use in
fact if you guys are familiar with our
g-cloud tool it's g-cloud compute
instances create then - - preemptable
and just hit enter to create a regular
vm you're just free move that -
preemptable and you've got a regular vm
many of our customers are actually using
them for real this isn't sort of like
excess compute that's just sitting on
the side and that we're sort of giving
away as fire prices we have clusters and
you'll hear from Bert we have clusters
that are you know over 10,000 cores but
some things to keep in mind one same
great VMs same great disk options same
great networking same images etc almost
every feature that's available for
regular VMs are available for
preemptable but we can and do preempt
them that's why they're called
printables is right there in the name
you get what you pay for
we give you if we do decide to preempt
your VM we'll give you 30 seconds worth
of notice and then we will send a
shutdown signal you can use a shutdown
script as usual to handle the shutdown
event and then backup your data or do
what you need but you get a 30 seconds
of those the other caveat is we only
give you 24 hours of our time if your VM
is not preempted in the
24 hours and we just shut it down for
you and of course there's no less device
or guarantees because when we can take
the thing away
what kind of SLA it's gonna give you all
right so usually when I tell this to
people they're like okay this just
sounds crazy right like you're gonna
give me a commercial machine I'm gonna
pay you very relatively a little for it
but you're gonna just take it away
whenever like what can I possibly do
with them well the idea is that you're
not doing something with one virtual
machine you probably have a few of them
and you have some workload and the best
places where these are applicable is
when you have a workload that has a lot
of individual units that are independent
and small relative to the workload right
so let's take the example of a media
transcoding let's say you have a few
million images that might be coming from
a satellite or being uploaded to some
website or something something something
and what you want to do is you want to
take all these images and you want to
transcode them into some other format
maybe you want to rescale them maybe you
want a grayscale them whatever it is
what you'll do is you'll put these
images in some storage location and
we'll talk about your options for that
in a little bit you will have a master
node that is definitely not preemptable
thank you you'll use a master node that
is a standard VM because you generally
don't want your master node going away I
haven't seen any scenario where
anybody's used to appear at the moment
astronaut yet
and then you'll spin up a whole bunch of
preemptable machines you will take
images out of that storage location one
at a time you will assign them to the
preemptable machines and they'll start
actually running the code that you have
on those machines and they will actually
do the computation for you no chance the
transcoding of the images of course if
one of your machines does get preempted
and they will get preempted you haven't
really lost anything all you lost is the
work through trance code that one image
all you will do is your master node will
realize oh hey we lost this machine this
image never got transcoded so I'm just
gonna cue it back up and assign
different preemptable or maybe to
another or similar machine and so on so
that's a pretty common use case there's
obviously others there's satellite image
analysis that are surrendering like I
mentioned data analysis genomics
financial analysis and there are some
things you can type into your favorite
search engine to get some some articles
and blog posts cool alright so also
actually talked about data and storage
as you guys know on GC P we have a
bewildering amount of storage options
for you
in fact what's actually missing from the
slide is the fact that we announce
spanner today and today I'm going to
talk about - primarily we're gonna talk
about our object storage options and
block storage options that's persistent
disk and Google Cloud storage
of course you will still use things like
relational databases or no sequel
databases in your batch scenarios for
example if you're transporting images
again you might want to say you know for
this image the target resolution is X
the target color depth is y there's some
metadata associated with that image that
you want stored and persisted or perhaps
you have different priorities for the
jobs and Sarah cool so let's talk about
block storage just to be a little
clearer block storage single block
storage is a regular hard drive attached
to your PC right and we have three
primary options we have localist as the
persistent disk and we have two flavors
of persistent disk SSD persistent disk
and hard drive persistent disk let's
start on the far left with vocalist is
the local SSD is our fastest option so
if you have a batch job that's
constantly referencing files or it's
working with a specific file over and
over over again or just really needs low
latency you're gonna go with local SSD
like the name implies it's actually
physically attached to the VM to the
hardware that your VM is running on
that's why it's local on the flip side
it's ephemeral which means that once
your VM is terminated your local SSD is
just goes away
it's really good for like I said a
scratch space we when you're actually
working with the data locally you needed
you needed to be hot scientific or
clothes especially if you're using
something like GPU instances and you
just really want to chew through data
quickly it has great iOS performance of
course it is the priciest of the three
options and you can get up to 3
terabytes of it moving to the middle
column you have persistent discusses the
and after that you have persistent
discard drive
unlike local SSD persistent disks are
like a name implies persistent as you
can see we're very clear with our naming
preemptable VMs are preemptable
persistent disks are persistent you get
what you pay for there you know you have
if you need a persistent disk us fast
you'll go with persistent SSD it's a
little bit more pricey than persistent
this hard drive but you get great I ops
performance both of these get used 64 up
to 64 terabytes of space the everything
supports encryptions and persistent
disks also support snapshotting cool
alright so those that's disk and block
storage and then we have of course
Google Cloud storage which offers object
storage in the cloud and we have four
offerings that I'm not gonna go into
great depth on because I don't really
you know I recommend you guys go through
our cloud storage talk if you missed it
I think it was actually earlier then I
recommend you guys check it out record
it online or just check out our website
but suffice it to say that we have four
options cold line is the sort of lowest
SLA and the assumption is that you're
accessing data on a rare occasion we
need it so this is like for archival
storage and then we have multi regional
offerings that have very high ISO lays
and their geo redundant so you can
access your data from a number of
regional cloud regions around the world
all right the house is different than
persistent disk so latency is higher on
the flip side you can store a lot of
data it dastar scales to exabytes
whereas persistent disk as I mentioned
before scales to 64 terabytes
unlike persistent disk it's available
from anywhere in the world you can use
are the rest interface over HTTP just to
request the files you need persistent
this has to be attached to GCE VM
obviously you can expose it from there
but inherently it's attached to GCE VM
it's higher latency like I mentioned and
of course this isn't block storage so
you can't append to a file you can
specify can't read specific blocks you
can just insert overwrite read entire
files at a time
it offers versioning and of course is
cheaper so what I'm hoping that you guys
get out of this is there's a continuum
of storage options that you have and you
know the one extreme you have cold line
and then the other extreme you have
local SSD and what you probably want to
do is you want to fix notches along that
continuum and say hey from my perform
for my application I'm actually
computing I need to be perhaps on local
SSD or perhaps persistent discusses the
and then when maybe when I'm not
actually using my data or for the data
I'm not using or using very early I like
put into cloud storage maybe I'll put it
into
the cold line and so on cool let's talk
about actual batch architectures so this
is these are sort of samples and what we
see in customers built on Google Cloud
this is a very basic starter batch
architecture right over here you have
our Google Cloud Storage buckets one of
them stores the input data sorry again
if we're going back to the running story
through this talk is image transcoding
if you have a bunch of images you might
put your input images into the input
bucket over here you'll have some
analysts or some maybe it's not a human
being maybe it's a machine that's
creating the images and putting them in
and it's putting them into the input
bucket you'll have a head node that is
definitely not running a pre interval VM
and it's running some software like HD
calendar or slurm or maybe custom
scripts that you wrote and it's spinning
up virtual machines to go out and talk
to to read data from the input buckets
do the actual computation the
transcoding or the analysis whatever it
is that you want to do and then it
actually writes the output data to the
output bucket okay so let's say you've
been doing that for a while and things
are going well and then you kind of
realize like all right well this is I'm
sure waiting for these files to come
down from Google Cloud Storage and it's
taking some time I want something that's
a little faster a little lower latency
what you would probably do in that case
is you would take the existing start a
batch architecture and you would add to
it a bunch of persistent disks right so
you would have you create a parallel
file system with some compute nodes and
some persistent disks that allow you to
basically effectively cache the data
from Google Cloud storage on closer to
the actual compute instances for the
time for the moment when you're actually
doing the computation and of course you
can use a variety of options like NFS or
a year or a luster or orange FS and so
on moving on from there at some point
you'll probably realize like oh wait my
workload is like embarrassingly parallel
and if I lose work you know if I lose a
machine that's perfectly fine and why am
I not saving like 80 percent by using
preemptable VMs and so what you'll
probably do is you'll create two pools
of workers one of them will be running
pre on twelve VMs and in other one will
be running during regular nodes it's
generally advisable that you guys don't
just run 100
and printables it's kind of something
that's 80% off I get it but depending on
your business need and how much progress
you need to make you need to kind of
make a call about what the split is I've
seen people do it 6040 5050 forty sixty
thirty seventy and so on the thing of
course is that preemptable VMS are
preemptable we can take them away and
sometimes we ever need to take away a
lot of them and so you want to be
guaranteed that you know your jobs don't
crawl to a halt and your progress
doesn't crawl to a halt and so it's a
good idea to depending on your needs to
have some number of preempt of standard
VMS all right and beyond that you might
go out and grow your application even
more so in this example we're adding
auto scaling and health checks and I'll
talk a little bit about how that works
on GCE
and this lets you basically say hey if
there's nothing going on in my in my in
my queue if there's nothing in there
because this middle tonight or maybe
it's a long weekend and all the analysts
went home and nobody submitting anything
just turn off all the machines because
why should be paying for it health
checks basically say hey if one of my
machines is funky or it's not responding
just kill the thing and start it over
again or if it got preempted create a
new one of course we have the file
system as before and we're still using
Google Cloud Storage for the ultimate
backup you might have added alerting and
monitoring with stackdriver
maybe all of this is being computed in
output somewhere and then you actually
want to visualize it or like give your
analyst that opportunity through some
interactive analysis after the
computation and of course you might add
up a backup node but ok so let's walk
through a concrete example where you're
actually doing satellite image analysis
so you at the very top you have your
image source and what that image source
does is it takes images of the earth or
whatever it is and pushes it at an
interest node which is just the VM takes
the data does some preliminary analysis
on let's say for example puts it into
cloud storage and then writes some
metadata about that image into cloud
datastore and it also notifies the head
node that are hey we have something in
the queue the head node then goes
doesn't intelligent and that brief
analysis of the data puts it in the
queue and tells the computer knows to go
hey you can actually go and start
working on
on this thing the compute nodes of
course can also take into account we
have this Landsat data on Google Cloud
storage which is free satellite data
they take this data put it together and
then they actually write the output to
do the computation and they write the
output data to Google Cloud storage and
then your analysts can come back and
then the connection use things like
bigquery or a cloud data lab to analyze
the results one thing that I'd like to
tell people when I talk about building
batch systems and cloud is if you've
ever built one of these things before
you're probably built you're probably
used to working in this mode right you
have an on-premise cluster of maybe some
thousands of course and all your cores
are pretty much the same thing and they
are one size fits all because you need
to you need them for everybody in your
organization and you build a single
queue and everybody in your organization
starts using that queue maybe they get
different priorities or you have some
way of trading off time etc but
generally what happens is that queue
gets longer and longer and longer and
people get angrier and angrier and
angrier I've been in that situation I've
been in the end of that queue in the
cloud you don't actually have to build
that way first of all you don't have to
buy one size fits all machines you can
actually do that with one of your
clusters but then you might realize that
a whole bunch of people in your
organization they actually need GPUs so
in the old world you'd probably go out
and buy some GPU machines with us you
can probably run them but you can run
the plate a minute you might realize
that a whole bunch of other people they
need high CPU machines which are
machines that have more CPU higher CPU
to memory ratio and yet somebody else
needs higher memory Sheens would have
high memories that have more memory than
they do a higher memory to CPU ratio
than a standard machine and so you can
actually do is spin up clusters for each
of them and give you should on their own
queue so they're not really competing
with each other for time they're
competing with themselves right and they
can choose to make priorities and
trade-offs as they need and then you
control how much they spend essentially
by controlling the size of the cluster
so in the old world you used to have
queues that will just get infinitely
long in the cloud you're gonna have
lower queue times which leads to people
actually being able to iterate faster
and that usually hopefully
as meaningful business results you guys
aside from just people who are happier
and there's less anger you listen
fighting and then each virtual cluster
has a nose that actually fit the
workload that that customer the internal
customer of yours actually needs rather
than just buying one-size-fits-all
hardware which least of course laces
loss resources and less costs and of
course when somebody doesn't need those
GPU machines you can scale them down and
just turn the whole thing off or
somebody doesn't at high mem 32 cluster
you can just turn off the cluster
entirely and because we build by the
minute this makes perfect sense there's
no reason why you should be paying for
machines that are sitting cold and in
the event that you somebody pushes a
change to one of your clusters and
breaks the thing because it was a bad
configuration or something that's just
their cluster that's broken not the
entire not everybody in the world
together all right let's talk about some
best practices on cloud how do you save
money how do you scale and how do you
simplify your life let's talk about
saving money first so as I mentioned a
couple of times do use for your VMs if
you can make sense there 80% off you mix
in with your regular VMs and you make
the progress that way use custom machine
types custom machine types is something
that I think was actually mentioned by
words in his talk earlier in the keynote
essentially basically lets you do what
you see up in that upper left corner
over there
excuse me upper right corner where you
can actually select how many cores and
how many ram you want in a single
machine right you're after by machines
as power of two powers of two if he
needs 14 cores or you need 12 cores you
can actually just set the slider to 14
course and the star so this
corresponding memory slider to what you
need and that lets you fit you know the
actual machine to the job not try to fit
the job onto the machine another cool
feature that we have is instance right
sizing recommendations and that's what
you see over here you see those little
yellow light bulbs I guess that's
basically where we sort of look at the
machine and go like hey this thing's
being underutilized you have a very
large machine but you're using very
little actual you're not using all 14
course that you've selected so maybe you
just turn it down and save some money so
this is just a very brief over your
whole your options
for those of you who chose the king come
here thank you very much
at this moment right now there's a
parallel session going on wants to save
money saving money on compute engine so
please find the recording of it
afterwards and check out check it out a
few or more details on all the various
options that we have all right now
simplifying your life and making making
you happier obviously Google compute
engine is infrastructure as a service we
provide raw VMs and at networking but we
also provide some managed infrastructure
services to make your life a little bit
easier so for instance auto-scaling you
don't actually build your own autoscaler
we allow you to define groups of
instances and then apply one of our
existing autoscaler technologies to it
so that we actually do the scaling for
you based on the rules that you specify
how do healing super idea you define
what it means for your app to be healthy
we take a look at it and and if it's not
healthy we kill it and started over
again based on the instance group but
this by the way is actually very useful
with preemptable VMs because machine is
preempted is not healthy and if you have
a managed in this group of pre huntable
VMs and you say i want this group to
stay at 100 nodes and one of them gets
preempted this thing a lot of matically
detect an interest create a new one and
of course there's also rolling updates
and other and other goodness and also
going on at the same time as a talk on
managing this group so if you guys are
interested please do check out that
video ok this is I believe my last slide
scaling and compute engine this is also
sort of in spirit of do not or as much
as you can try to avoid building this
stuff yourself it gets complicated
pretty fast we have a great solution
which is essentially a tutorial on our
website called HT condo scaling and on
Google cloud with HT calendar or like
basically search for HT calendar on
Google cloud and you will find a
tutorial and a solution that lets that
teaches you how to use HD Condor which
is a batch management open source
application that lets you build batch
solutions on Google Cloud relatively
straightforward and it make takes
advantage of preemptable VMs as well
alright that's what I have and I'm gonna
turn over to Bert to talk about the
goodness have done the Fermilab thank
you Michael
ok everybody can hear me okay
[Applause]
okay so I'll talk about how we
provisioned 160,000 cores with what we
call hep cloud hep is jargon for honty
physics and actually before I even get
into physics I should mention I have to
do the legal boilerplate here so I work
for a government lab so I'm not giving
any specific endorsement to Google even
though I've had a Google conference I
can't endorse cloud products I can't
endorse clothing lines at Nordstrom's
you get the idea okay so you know we're
trying to answer a hold on you're now
reading this in Morgan Freeman's voice
we're trying to answer basic questions
about the universe so what's the
universe made of how would it form it
would basically what what's the past
present and future of the universe and
and the highe physics of high-energy
physics of high-energy physics this is
what we're aiming to answer so you know
everything everything on this planet is
you see it's actually here in this
periodic table you all had high school
chemistry I hope and that you can see
the blue line that covers what things
are made of out to the atomic level but
atoms are also made of things and we'll
dive down deeper into what those are
made of and so this periodic table was
invented in the actually the 19th
century be and this is the periodic
table for the you know for the present
term quark slept these are the things
that we're doing these are things were
investigating in high-energy physics and
actually ordinary matter the quarks the
up and down pork there and the gluon and
the electron that's all your ordinary
matter here too and in the center is the
Higgs boson which I hope you all heard
about a couple years ago and I'll come
back and discuss that in a bit
Fermilab so what is Fermilab we are the
United States from your lab for studying
this field of high energy physics it
always looks like this even though we're
40 miles outside of Chicago right and we
do completely unclassified research the
site's open to the public we're the only
National Lab that does they believe has
zero classified research there's my
office not the whole building but
somewhere on the knife
the fully at Fermilab what do we have so
we have a decent sized facility on
premises we've got almost 50,000 cores
we've got a tape capacity of 100
petabytes we've got 35 petabytes of disk
and we have pretty good network
connectivity of multiple of a hundred
gigabit so we have a pretty good
resources on-site and we're all sigh
also work for the government so we know
how to and I work for science or we we
do this as cheaply as we can and
probably pay people as cheaply as we can
unfortunately so I should mention we're
also the largest of computing facility
outside of Geneva Switzerland Geneva for
high-energy physics and do Hardy physics
to Sproule these extremely small scales
you need extremely big machines this is
a Large Hadron Collider in Geneva
Switzerland the the ring is about 17
miles around and to give you an idea if
it was here if there's a center here it
almost stretches out to the Presidio and
so it's it's a it's a big machine and
I'm gonna talk about some of the one of
the experiments these are underground
there's a couple of interaction points
I'll be talking about CMS so one of the
experiments at the Large Hadron Collider
this is CMS that's not me
but do you be a sense of scale of the
experiment you know these are big it's a
it's a big ring it's a weird for being
extremely tiny things and so it's it's a
strange but you need something extremely
big to detect then okay so the the and
also the the CMS experiment and this is
the CMS experiment stands for compact
muon solenoid
I know compact seems strange in this
context but what happens so we have
protons colliding 14 million times per
second and is essentially a really large
camera that takes pictures of and we
keep about it we canwe about a thousand
at about a kilohertz so a thousand times
per second we keep this data and all
measurements of a proton proton
collision we call it an event it's a
little different from it events I heard
about earlier we talk about publishing
the queues and so on these are events
they have physical content
and this is a very complicated beast so
we need simulations to understand what
we're doing and so we have simulations
that go from a stage where we're
basically rolling the dice and doing
random Y elating events with Monte Carlo
simulation through simulating the
passage of particles through matter and
how they radiate and Howard it's to
responds and in the end reconstructing
physics quantities not only is it sector
complicated quantum physics is in our
way too so we can't control our initial
conditions precisely and we're only
really sampling a part of the space and
so we need to use these probabilistic
techniques to sample these spaces and
and when we analyze this we compare our
simulation and extract physics results
ok let me see if I get the movie going
here so you can see a which will
distract you while I talk so here's a
plot of the Higgs boson well it's not
the Higgs boson yeah well you see is the
black dots or data filling in the blue
is a simulation of the standard model
that's that's everything except the
Higgs boson in that new periodic table I
showed you and the red curve corresponds
to a new theory in this case it's the
Higgs boson and what you see as it fills
in as you can see the Higgs boson start
to emerge not just in our simulation but
you can also you see in the data and the
error bars will get smaller as more and
more data gets accumulated so these
simulations are critical of particle
physics and we're Statistics driven we
need a lot of them we need a huge amount
of data oh I have to move this back over
yeah okay so the scale of simulations we
need we're simulating on the order of
the billions and billions
I sound like Carl Sagan we're simulating
a lot of simulate of collisions per year
these experiments of the Large Hadron
Collider needed and workflows are I'm
gonna use a different term than Michel
they're not embarrassing for a little
pleasingly parallel we have the benefit
of having these really weakly coupled
things we can run in batch and do it
efficiently so every event that we
simulate every collision can be simulate
can be done separately on its own core
in parallel and so we need a lot of
compute to do this at Fermilab not every
devoted to CMS there's 70 data centers
throughout the world we've been doing
this we've been doing this compute
computing in this field for since the
dawn of computing really and and driven
it for a long time so we've been doing
this particular the LHC turned on less
than a decade ago and so we have 70 data
centers throughout the world these are
universities these are National Labs
these are the international laboratories
CERN and labs all throughout the world
tale the tape here there's about a
hundred fifty thousand cores world wide
available to this experiment
seventy-five petabytes of spinning discs
100 petabytes of used tape space and we
have strong networks connecting all the
sites not just at Fermilab so we can
transfer data back and forth we move
about five petabytes back and forth
across all the sites every week and
across the Atlantic we also have 340
gigabits a second that's one of the
things we exercised early on make sure
we get the data from Geneva to Fermilab
as quickly as we could that's not enough
that's a lot of compute but it's not
enough and I'll show you why you are
here we're in the middle of run to where
we've got about 158 petabytes of data
for the experiment but we have an
upgrade coming in the next five to ten
years where we're going to need
estimated of 1920 exabytes of data
that's this petabytes is big this is
ridiculously huge so we're gonna need a
lot of compute to chew through that we
need to do it cheaply because we're well
we work for the government and we're
trying to get every bang for our buck
that we can without raising your taxes
the other interesting thing for us as a
field is that when you when I was asked
about this five ten five years ago about
cloud computing the costs were the costs
were just too high because like I said
we buy cheap we bid we we do things as
shoestring but the cost has come down
here's just a plot of the costs over
time and they're they're monotonically
decreasing to the point where this
becomes attractive for us to use
commercial cloud so a challenge so we we
we got a through a wonderful coincidence
of X Fermi people working at Google and
the right people being in the right type
line at the wrong time at the wrong time
at the right time
well we we attempted we so we asked
ourselves can we double the reach of
this experiments compute let's do a live
demo because you know why not
and we'll do supercomputing which is a
conference back in November for days 12
hours a day while the exhibit floor is
open
let's and let's do it by expanding
Fermilab using something called Hep
cloud to 160,000 cores and let's do it
so the application doesn't really notice
so what's hep cloud and I didn't name
this this is named by the head of the
office of science but the idea is it's
basically a portal for our researchers
where we decide when we decide where
we're going to send their workflows
whether we're going to keep them
in-house on Prem whether we're going to
send them to the grid to Google cloud to
the other cloud up north that I probably
shouldn't mention to our supercomputing
partners we have facilities at Argonne
Lab Oak Ridge lab at Berkeley at nurse
and so we started a pilot project to
explore our capabilities collaborating
with act with industry and academia and
the goal is to move well I was given the
guidelines you should get this into
production in fiscal year 18 and so the
last day of fiscal year 18 September
30th so I'm going to get it in by
September 30 2018 so we're in the R&D
phase and the architecture I don't have
a pointer so I'm not going to go through
this in tremendous detail but on the
left of the dashed line we have a user
submitting workflows they comes into our
facility and we have a decision engine
and the decision engine decides when
we're going to provision based on
workflow characteristics based on the
pricing what the preemptable czar are
going are going for compared to what it
cost us on Prem what's available in the
grid and so on and then we either send
it on tram or we have a provision or
that goes out and gets all these
different classes of resources depending
on what makes sense and and in terms of
the implementation how do we do this we
have a technology that was called AG
line WMS we talk about HD counter a
little bit in the last call we use it we
use Condor for two things we use the
provision resources week we go ahead and
send in a pilot we have an it's a cold
completely different talk Y pilot based
workflow management is a good idea
and when I don't have time for it here
but essentially we launch pilots on the
workflows it's not it goes ahead and
pulls workflows jobs out of the queue
and it helps validate environment it it
manages the fact these resources may
look different and to the users it can
look like a common pool even at the
facility it'll look like a common pool
and we use Connor to accomplish this all
right so you know let's let's look a
little closer at the architecture of
what we're doing inside a single zone so
we have a provisioner talking to the
google cloud api's and then we we go
ahead and and that launches our worker
nodes we do it we did everything with
preemptable DMS because they're they're
priced right for us and there's no
critical these are we have enough to
fault tolerance built-in if something
gets preempted we just resubmit the job
there's no magic state we have to keep
with these things because every
collision is independent we used and and
I'll talk about the details of this in a
bit it calls back to our head node for
our overlay batch system it sent data
back out to Fermilab to the object store
we ran our input data from Google Cloud
Storage and we also had a we need to get
the application software to the to
Google in a way that the the end user
doesn't notice and so we used some web
caches to provide the application
software as well as job by job
calibration data a caching later in
front of our off-site DB we didn't just
use one zone we if we're gonna scale
that high it's advisable to do more for
preempt so we covered four zones in
central one you can see the the
architecture overall and we were reading
everything from a regional bucket from
our input data displayed in the middle
okay so the break apart some of the
pieces here so HD Condor this is a batch
system but also our provisioner it
speaks cloudy API it's initially written
it's written by Matt uh the university
wisconsin madison team it's been around
for a long time and is where google
helped us out they contributed to this
open source project they added support
for this to speak preemptable VMS and
serve as accounts and actually they
fixed a critical bug which we found the
friday before the word
to get the demo on Monday to address
scaling where we couldn't get beyond we
couldn't get anywhere close where we
needed to be how do we provide the
software to the application this is a
it's not this is maybe a field specific
technology but essentially we have
something called CERN VMFS it's named
after sir in the laboratory in
Switzerland where was developed it's
basically a web CT n to distribute our
application software and the idea being
that we have terabytes of software
sitting out there on a disk on disk we
go ahead and just cache the bits that we
need it's it's very efficient we need
and and also a lot gives us the
flexibility instead of sending a single
application out of the cloud we have we
can have many many different versions
provided to our end users doing this
doing the sending the scientific
workflows and and they don't they don't
know about any of this this is
completely transparent to the user okay
and so we had a managed in scroop we had
a managed instance group doing squid web
caching if there's anything that we know
cloud providers are terrific at and
Google's terrific at its web right so
it's an internal facing cache using the
il bees and we set it to auto scale
probably conservatively when the rates
one of nine megabytes per second and I
give you some more stories as I go on
nothing's perfect so we had an issue
these are squids and there's health
checks built in where they go ahead and
they try to get a file out of your web
server that's great for standard web
servers it's awful for squids because
squids are proxies when you do a get on
a squid it's getting not slash blah blah
blah but it's getting HTTP and so on so
and the and the the health checks only
took something with a leading slash so
unfortunately squid has some internal
URI so that was our solution our hack to
go pull those in so if you try to do
this this will help you
we pre staged our input data to GCS so
so we have an experiment we distributed
computing for a long time with a lot of
data so there's a lot of field specific
technology that we use we have Express
at specific data placement services
which schedules transfers places
datasets and so on just this year the
technologies were using in the have
speak are starting to speak the right
cloud languages in particular they speak
the moment they speak s3 and so we're
able to use the s3 compatibility modes
such transfer data in and we're able to
do it at 10 gigabit and 10 get the only
reason we're limited by 10 gigabit is
the our object store I could not do
third-party transfers without upgrading
some bits of it and we needed to get
half a petabyte in and we had a week we
had enough time to do it so i just let
it completely redline the nick at 10
gigabit and we let it go and we access
these data via using GCSE views on sort
of so we access over fused mounts look
like slash whatever whatever to the to
the application which was great and it
performed very well and along the way to
not just to make sure the input was
working but the output looked like we
were going to need more than 10 gigabit
at the scale we're talking about so so
thanks to Google and also our energy
Sciences network the peering was
upgraded 100-year give it temporarily
for the for for our work and then
ironically that was actually scheduled
to get upgraded a couple months later so
it's a hundred gigabit now we also
converted we had a regional bucket for
cloud storage we converted that
overnight to save costs as we want to
realize that we were fine we had enough
capacity in a single region overnight
half a petabyte was converted and it
cost us 30 percent less ok so right
there's a big question right I talked to
all this gave you all the architecture
question is how do we do that we'd agree
so this is the course from Google this
is a plot from our own dashboards for
the running at CERN and the different
colors you see here everything else
everything that's not purple our
different sites you know the red is the
red which is let's see I don't have a
pointer but the red that's next that's
on top that's Fermilab and everything
else this is everything we run all over
the world during this time
and what you see is we doubled the
computing capacity for the experiment
300,000 cores contributing to science to
high-energy physics during this time and
here's a plot from our dashboards
we're ingesting this in the graph Anna
and they and the money plot I have other
plots at 160,000 but there's one I took
a nice screenshot the money plot is the
one all the way in the middle of the pie
chart the the yellow is everything that
we have all over the world all these
seventy data centers running and in
teraflops per second and teraflops and
the the green is is what we're getting
from from GCE
so we were able to hit our target and I
should say we were able to do this in we
got to go ahead to do this three and a
half weeks before the conference before
the server computing so we were able to
do it in record time thanks thanks all
sort of thanks to the Fermilab and also
a great team at Google all right so what
are some lessons we learned you know
Michael talked about the custom machine
types we started out with a standard
machine type that's more than we needed
we trimmed it down and it was extremely
easy to do so and there was a 20% cost
savings
I mentioned the code that Google helped
us fix we had a bug in our there was a
bug in the code it's been there ever
since Connor put in support for GCE
which has probably been three four or
five years it ignored the AP pagination
API which you know is it really shows up
in funny ways because you get an alpha
ties list of VMs that we're getting
deleted out from under us because our
our stay we had no idea what our stay
was Google provided the patch and then
here's a fun one as we're expanding
capacity in the zone in the region we
went from 4k to 16 K IPs there should be
a character in there but it's a simple
API command g-cloud compute network
subnets expand IP range and so on that's
great except maybe you see the problem
in that red 20 right there in the
firewall yeah 20 is 4k 20 bits is 4k so
we ran into that we fixed it but when
you go to scale these are sorts of
things you discover we would have never
discovered this pagination bug if we had
kept it 10,000 cores or something small
all right so you know here are some of
the numbers the tale the tape so to
speak we ran about six almost six and a
half million hours of wall time on these
resources we had five and a half four
completed jobs we submitted more than
seven hundred thirty thousand of these
simulation jobs in each job is more than
one collision it's a whole host of them
only 47 didn't complete because we have
fault tolerance with our batch we have
fault tolerance
with the application that feeds the
badge and once we got out of the infant
mortality of the first day of the demo
when we found some of these issues like
that firewall issue was day one where
we're hardly where we spent a lot of
time hacking at laptops to get to the
bottom of that the good put in other
words which is a was at 94% in other
words six percent of the cycles that we
had were wasted in results we didn't get
back 94% of our compute came back to us
even though we're using exclusively
preemptable VMs so we had a terrific
result that's better than a lot of our
grid sites which are not necessarily
dependable well it depends which
University and lab you're going to it's
a host of sites but that's better than a
lot of our grid computing sites
it's that I I'd be fired if it was
better than Fermilab probably or but so
it's I think we'd do well it depends on
what the jobs are doing to in terms of
the costs so if you were the cost this
is what a cost us during supercomputing
the main cost was the not surprisingly
the cost of compute for the VMS it cost
us about eight and a half K for network
address you pay for every bite you get
out of the network we have a we optimize
the workflow so they didn't bite us too
much there other workflows will cost
more the disk that's attached to the VMS
that we needed for our workflows and
then the storage that half a petabyte
that we stored cost about $3500 we
generate 200 million physics events ok
eighty-one terabytes of data for the
experiment and in terms of the cost and
these costs have a lot of caveats built
in so it ended up costing us about 1.6
cent per core our on-premises our costs
are about a little less than a cent per
car but that makes a bunch of
assumptions number one there were a
hundred percent utilized and
I work for Fermilab I won't show any
plots demonstrating anything different
it also keep in mind I work as I said
many times I work for the government and
Fermilab being this high-energy physics
frontier we have a Collider at at
Fermilab it's it's a it's a big deal and
it we get power for cheap because it's a
lot believe me it may have cost you a
lot to run power to your data center but
running a proton proton Collider is is
is quite a lot of power so we get a good
rate on our power so we did this for CMS
for this experiment I talked about the
Large Hadron Collider we had some
credits left over we had some impetus to
see what we could do after
supercomputing so how quickly could we
onboard a new user somebody that hasn't
done anything with GCE the CMS is part
of this run up so there's experiment
called beauty I won't go into the
physics in any detail but the basic idea
is trying to measure the rare decay of
muons two electrons which has never been
observed and so it would be a complete
change to the standard model of particle
physics this it would be really
interesting the experiments getting
designed now so it's in the design stage
of trying to figure out where to put all
these bits and I won't tell I won't talk
about the technical bits of what these
things are but where do you put the
detectors and and and optimize them so
that's where we're simulating different
placement different geometry how big
should things be for this detector so
how quickly do we get them onboard
listen a date they were ready for just
now this is an experiment that knew how
to do grid computing distributed
computing but we had all the tools in
place they were prepared and it took us
less than a day after supercomputing to
get them up on GCE and what you see here
is the green is Google Cloud and the
yellow is what we're running for them on
Prem at Fermilab so that's a it's a
terrific result I think and it and it's
it shows that you know the fiower field
actually having been prepared for
distributed computing understands what
they need to understand some of the
things they need to do to be able to
bring stuff into the cloud all right so
what are we doing next
like I said we're moving for auction in
September 2018 we have this decision
engine component which is I think really
interesting the heart of it it's also
extremely difficult and I don't need to
get anything optimal in there but that's
an RD our super department of energy and
again this is your tax dollars at work
but we have supercomputers HPC
facilities and these are becoming much
more friendly for data intensive
workflows and so we're provisioning
cycles already at at Berkeley at nurse
on Edison and Cori and we're expanding
this there's additional commercial cloud
providers I talked about Google we've
done something similar with Amazon next
Ivy there's you know everybody next on
the you know we're you know since I
worked for the government I I have to
put things out to bid and I and where we
spread things as we spread the manure
over as many fields as we can get to
right and then there's non pleasingly
parallel problems so you know deep
learning there are I taught there's a
lot of compute involved with doing the
doing these simulations and doing the
data reconstruct with reconstruction we
do on our data but we have other
interesting problems that may lend
themselves well the deep learning we
have thousands of tons of liquid argon
detectors where we're looked looking for
3d tracks and when you start looking at
what you need to do with this it looks
an awful lot like image classification
and 3d problems and so there the field
is actually starting to reimburse a deep
learning that there was a the field
embraced neural when it was called
neural networks the the field got got
involved but we didn't have the compute
I think we probably had enough data in
the field but we didn't have the compute
to really make a sea change and how we
did our analyses and new architectures
all right so I just wanted to thank this
isn't my just my work it's a work of
cast of many so we have a great team at
Fermilab that did the work the HT Condor
and Glenda messed projects open science
grid I didn't talk much about this
except in the constants of Grid but a
lot of the stuff that sits underneath
the software packaging the tooling the
CERN VMFS the stuff that gets packaged
when things land on our worker nodes
they have all the tools we need from the
open science for his collaborative
project between the National Science
Foundation and the Department of Energy
the energy sciences network and none of
this you can't do any of this without
networking data intensive science
our team at Google Michael Curran
Solomon Sam Paul the Paul's and Doug
strain and you know I again I work for
the government I can't buy stuff
directly from Google either your terms
and conditions are things I can't agree
to so we need to go through resellers
that that take care of that for us
and I can't advertise for commercial
products by will advertise for the
laboratory so we're it's our 50th
anniversary at Fermilab if you're
anywhere in Chicago come by this year
there's a website we've got symposia
we've got a big birthday celebration
we're gonna have an enormous open house
campus is open to the public please come
by and that's it thank you
[Music]
[Music]